i'm abe this is kyle we're going to talk
about how to create a shared standard
for data quality in case anybody else
wants to do that we are currently
engaged in creating a shared standard
for data quality at great expectations
and
most of this talk is going to be about
community building open source just kind
of how those pieces fit together
um let's dive in with quick
introductions let's see do we have a
clicker yep right there okay i am not
trained in the use of this thing
hey okay you push the button
i'm abe uh
data science data engineer a data
scientist data engineer by training i've
been doing that for almost 10 years out
of grad school and that includes a mix
of work both in tech first companies
like jawbone and also more kind of
classic enterprise like aspire health
i care a lot about the human-centric
ethical use of data i might talk about
that a little bit more later if there's
time
and in the meantime
core contributor for great expectations
ceo co-founder at super
and uh
mid pandemic move to salt lake city
just quick quick show of hands who in
the room has moved since the pandemic
started
okay
interesting uh who who moved from a
relatively crowded place like a city to
a relatively less crowded place like a
smaller city
okay
yeah
everybody's talked about this like great
migration that's going on and it's fun
to actually like be here in person
um and yeah see a little bit of that
so that's me in a nutshell last thing to
say is i've got three awesome kids and
um
my only regret about being a data
council is that i don't get to be with
them for a few days but totally worth it
to be back in person with this crowd
kyle over to you
yeah so i'm kyle uh kyle eaton user
experience designer and researcher
mostly in pharma and biotech i'm a 500
startups alumni and i consider myself a
startup swiss army knife
i'm a community manager for great
expectations and a growth lead for
superconductive i actually did the
opposite i moved from ann arbor michigan
go blue to boston and instead of kids i
like pickling
good substitution
better response too
all right so my job in this talk is to
talk about why kyle is going to talk
about how and again our theme here is
creating a shared standard for data
quality um
again quick show of hands who in the
audience is familiar with great
expectations as a library this okay
that's gratifying to see i'll just say
because uh we first presented great
expectations publicly at strata i think
four years ago and at that point zero
people in the audience knew about it
because we were announcing it and then
two years ago we announced again uh kind
of like the fact that we were pivoting
the company to focus on development to
commercialization of great expectations
and at that point there was smattering
of people who knew about it but you know
not everybody we're getting to the point
where
i mean this is it is a thing that
everybody knows about that's that's
really fun so what we want to talk about
today is uh two things uh first just to
put it in context is uh why why we are
positioning great expectations as a
shared open standard
and then kyle is going to talk more
about how like what we're doing from a
community building community development
perspective
and just for a bit of context
the library has now existed for four
years the community around it is one of
the fastest growing communities in the
data world we have six thousand somewhat
people in the slack channel i imagine
they're a fair number there's people in
the room here
we're now at the point where in a given
month great expectations will be
downloaded more than four million times
from pi pi every single month uh and
we've just recently announced the
closing of our series b fund raise so
great expectations is here to stay uh
we're as i said starting to work on a
commercial product that goes alongside
open source and because of that we felt
like data council would be a really good
time and place to just make a clear
statement about what we are doing from
an open source perspective so if you
want to talk about great expectations
cloud and those things sure like we've
got a booth we can do that but this
presentation is about open source uh
where we've come from where we're going
and for my section for why i'm going to
approach it in two pieces one i'm going
to start from the back and start like
why data quality like what's the value
we're trying to create in the world
there and then from there i'll go to why
a shared standard is a particularly good
way of doing that
so uh like why data quality
okay good it animates i wasn't sure if
this would animate
um
we're living through this interesting
time where every organization is
becoming a data organization meaning the
ability to pull in data and wrangle it
and do that in a scalable way is just
becoming a critical function for every
organization that wants to move fast
enough to keep pace with the rest of the
world
we're building these nervous systems
that help organizations think and act in
concert
if you have time tristan handy from dbt
has a great talk from coalesce last year
on
the jellyfish and the salamander that
talks about different ways those nervous
systems can be structured different ways
they can evolve and i think a lot of
what we're doing as data people is
making it so that the organizations we
work within can think and act in concert
when you get into the kind of granular
nitty gritty of that it's all dags right
it's all pipelines it's flows of data
from source to destination with
transformation and augmentation and like
lots of other work in the middle and
kind of the key point i make about data
quality is this thing is it's a supply
chain right it's a supply chain for
decision making or sometimes a supply
chain for product features that are data
driven and in each case you need to make
sure that the supply chain has high
quality is secure at each step along the
way that doesn't necessarily mean you're
like deploying great expectations tests
at each step along the way but it does
mean that there needs to be a solid
notion of like what is it supposed to be
doing and can we guarantee that the
supply chain does that at each stage
and then if you take the same thing and
kind of turn it inside out at each stage
along the way there are different people
who are working with that data i really
liked proculpo's point from the the last
panel where she said that data is really
a multi-stakeholder problem there's no
one person who has all of the context
you have to have lots of different
people working together
and
so when i think about like practically
speaking what does that mean like what
as i've done data work what does that
look like
there's a huge difference between
working in an organization where
people have lots of different
expectations about data and where
there's shared unified expectations
about data like that that's really in
many ways kind of the heart of what it
means to have high quality equality is
this very abstract term when you look at
the nuts and bolts of what does it take
to guarantee it it's making sure that
different people agree on what should be
happening and that the software system
or the human system or like whichever
systems it is that's processing that
data do that in a reliable predictable
therefore high quality kind of way
so that that's kind of the big why for
this like we're going through this
really interesting phase in um human
like technical evolution where it's
possible to share
information and make decisions on a much
larger scale than you could before but
we haven't quite figured out how to do
that in a systematically consistently
high quality way
okay
so now i'm going to do
kind of like almost like a victory lap
in some cases of like all the things
that we are either building or have
built in great expectations that help do
that from a technical perspective help
get to those shared expectations across
an organization i'm going to brief i'm
going to touch on a few of these in more
detail and breeze through some of them
more quickly
so the first is you need to have a
support for a really broad vocabulary of
expectations i'm just going to throw
some of these up on the screen
all of these are real expectations that
are a little bit
they're not the people the ones that
people implement first they're the ones
that start to get more into the nooks
and crannies of specific problems
um at this point we've got
something like 80 live expectations and
plans for that to go at least in the low
hundreds pretty soon
um
and the reason that why we're doing that
is as people express what they think and
what they believe about data it's really
important to be able to have a language
that matches with them that follows
along um overall and this is one of the
the trends that we're seeing that
probably good for people to just kind of
also echo we'd love to get feedback from
others
i'm seeing this progression from kind of
engineering-centric concerns around data
quality so like does this column exist
um is it ever nullable
does the value go outside of fixed range
to things that are more statistical and
also more semantic starting to say not
just hey does this column match a
certain regex but
is that regex an email address oh is
that is that email address the email
address of a paying customer are they in
our database did they churn recently
starting to get semantic understanding
at that level um is i think a big part
of where this is going to go next
so broad vocabulary
a second one is facilitating
communication across lots of teams so
the last time that we were a data
council we announced this notion of
compile to docs the idea that in great
expectations um this language isn't just
a technical language of assertions about
data it's also a human language where
you can turn all of your tests into
documentation
and your docs or tests and those things
can move in lockstep
and as we've kind of watched the
evolution of that over the last couple
years
we've it's gotten more nuanced and to
give an example of that let me kind of
put a few examples of different ways
that you could take the same expectation
and express them with these kind of like
different twists on grammar so there's a
descriptive version like what is
happening in the data right now
there's also a prescriptive version like
what do you believe should be happening
in the data
there's a question which is okay like
okay what is the data doing there's an
answer and then there's a diagnostic
version which is here's what i expect
here's what actually is happening
if those line up everything's good if
those don't line up then oh wait a
minute like something should happen here
we need we need to go back and figure
out why that you know why does the world
not align with expectations there so
it's a subtle thing and it's you know
it's just grammar but when you i put it
to you that if you uh sit in data
meetings with people and watch how they
talk about data and how they ask
questions you'll see all five of these
different formats show up and if you
watch really closely you can actually
use this as sort of a window into where
in the life cycle of establishing shared
expectations as a team
so being able to produce all of these
kinds of things is
an interesting and i think a pretty
powerful part of what we're doing with
this shared library of great
expectations um what it does in my view
is takes what would be a purely
technical tool and elevates it to
actually be able to help with
communication
and again the job is to get many people
on the same page so communication's got
to be part of that
okay a few more and then i'll get out of
the technical stuff pretty quickly uh
consistent execution across many kinds
of infrastructure
so when great expectations started we
were focused initially on
python pandas and notebooks we then
expanded pretty quickly to also be able
to do sql
and from there we actually had community
contributions that pull us into the
world of spark we're not officially
doing tasks yet but we have people who
are using it that way
and lots of other
specific sql dialects and back ends
and this notion that you can have tests
that mean something like they're
semantically meaningful they help kind
of hold the team's expectations together
but they're not tightly tightly coupled
to specific infrastructure
that actually turns out to be really
important for two reasons one you often
have data that flows across lots of
different pieces of infrastructure
and it's not going to be expressed in
the same language all the way so you
could have data ingestion that's going
through s3 and spark and glue and then
you can have work going on in a data
warehouse and then you could have work
going on after that in
python and notebooks and desk and things
like that and so being able to have
shared expectations about the data that
flow through all of those
becomes a really important
capability
on top of that
especially as we start to see more big
enterprise users of great expectations
many of those are coming
they still have scars from the lock-in
era where you know big vendors would
sell them on a monolithic solution and
it was really hard to switch out it's
really nice to have the notion of
tests and logic that aren't deeply
deeply coupled to whatever database or
backend you're tied to at the moment
so that's another thing it's one of
these things where having a shared
library having shared implementation is
really helpful because no one team is
ever going to implement all of those
things but the tool is much more useful
when it can become this shared language
across all of those
and on top of that there are other
things so there's there's usability
there's assistance with eda and data
profiling performance
just setting up your production system
all of those are things where
i put it to you like this is a
conference of tool builders
this is not stuff that needs to be
reinvented it's like once it's built and
built well once it makes a lot more
sense to integrate with that and
make sure the value from that system
goes to a lot of other places rather
than having to build and rebuild and
re-rebuild
all right so bring that back together uh
i said earlier that it's all about
creating shared expectations the way
that you create shared expectations and
i don't mean in a technical sense i mean
like a very human anthropological sense
is by sharing tools and sharing
community and
um
there is no better way to build shared
tools than open source open source is
such a good way to build software that
works really really well and works well
in lots of places
there's also no other way to build a
shared language than have an open
community and by that i don't mean
specifically like the great expectations
slack community i mean the broader
community that's here
all of the people who are building tools
together and collectively having this
conversation about where the data
ecosystem goes
time check oh sorry that's louder when i
look down um
we started a little bit late there was
one slide i was going to put in
i'm going to do it um so we we don't
have the slide in here but i want to
make
sort of like a moral ethical appeal to
the crowd really briefly
because this is a thing that i care
about
um i think professionally most of us are
engaged with building these kinds of
shared nervous systems within specific
companies
but we're actually living in a period
where
the same sort of problems exist on a
whole social scale so like basically
every democracy in the world right now
is struggling with
at least two two things that come out of
today's information technology one is
it's really hard for us collectively to
share facts
um just like as a body politic agreeing
just on what has happened or why things
are happening or like just the basics of
like what is happening uh that's gotten
harder somehow in the last several years
and the kinds of information systems
that we're building within companies
should at least in principle be able to
help without broader problem
similarly we have a lot of systems that
become extremely non-transparent and
they're therefore hard to have
democratic accountability for them in
the ways that we've typically thought
about that and uh i'm not a techno
utopian i don't believe that you know
we're going to invent a data system that
suddenly makes democracy you know 10x
democracy because blockchain like that i
don't think that
purely technical solutions will work for
for human problems
but i do think that the craft that we're
building of helping helping groups of
people get on the same page about stuff
that's the thing that has social
implications that are bigger than any
one company and
part of the conversation that i hope we
can have a data council is how do we
help foster that with the kinds of tools
that we're building
okay so snuck one extra one in there
kyle let me hand it off to you to talk
about how
thanks abe
all right so
how we're going to do this folds
perfectly into our mission to build and
support an active community of data
practitioners
i'm happy to say that we've had a lot of
really great success with building this
community of data practitioners we've
covered most of the globe uh with more
than half of our community existing
outside of the north american region
we have over 6 500 slack members in our
community and over 13 000 people in our
community we consider get up activity
we have 258 contributors and we recently
crossed four million monthly pipeline
downloads so last month was four million
downloads which is amazing
uh so how are we going to continue to
foster this rich community of data
practitioners and translate it into
building the open and shared standard of
data quality together
so i'm going to go over a few major
points and how we'll achieve this
starting with these two
regular community meetings and
interacting in slack uh and then a much
faster turnaround time for contributors
since raising our series b we've
dedicated more resources into our
community
i've been putting together a team of uh
developer advocates so and and technical
writers we now have five developer
advocates we have a technical writer and
then myself as the community manager
um you'll probably notice actually that
there's more activity in our slack in
the past couple months
and that's because of this team that
we've been putting together has been
fostering good conversation and
interacting much more with our community
and we see a lot more liveliness our
community today so
with this team we not only put more
effort into supporting our community
events
slack conversations github issues
emerging prs but thanks to community
feedback we've been building and
enhancing our documentation along with
creating some tooling to empower our
to make an impact on the project
and in the spirit of celebrating
community contributions we built the
expectations gallery to show off these
amazing contributions while making our
expectations easier to discover and
one thing you'll notice in fostering our
community and like what we've been doing
to build it is implementing a sort of
positive feedback loop which i feel is
really important for a great community
we want to highlight all of the positive
momentum that happens whether it be
something small to something big could
just be sharing an article in the
community
it could be
answering someone else's question or
fixing a little piece of documentation
to bringing in like a big feature or a
major integration
so speaking of a positive feedback loop
and where we do it um
our community meetups are awesome and
it's a great place for us to celebrate
our community and and give some insights
into the product
so
in our community meetups we spend some
time going over the product roadmap to
maintain transparency we highlight
community contributions to the project
uh celebrate others who are who are
helping celebrate people who are helping
others in slack
we also highlight interesting
conversations around data quality
opportunities to collaborate and
opportunities give feedback on upcoming
features so started using github
discussions as a place to gain feedback
on uh
upcoming features whether they're in a
pr or just being discussed
so our community show and tells are an
awesome opportunity for people in the
community to show off their use case of
great expectations or share an article
that they've authored in data quality
space
we love highlighting other people's work
that they're proud of and i'm really
happy to say that we created a platform
for others to do that
so if you want to promote your content
in one of our community events or maybe
in our newsletter whether it's your use
case of great expectations
or it's uh you know
an article in the space feel free to
reach out to me
slack email or if you're here i'll be at
the booth
so the third major step uh is going to
be highlighting uh sorry it's going to
be a highly streamlined process for
getting contributions over the line
quickly and then also the expectations
gallery
so the expectations gallery which is
something that's live now it's great
expectations dot io slash expectations
you'll also see it in the header of our
of our site
it's a place where users of great
expectations can discover all the
existing expectations created by the
core team as well as the community
it not only highlights the contributors
of individual expectations which you can
see
on the right side is a specific
expectation with a list of contributors
who help create that specific
expectation or just add some properties
to it
but it also highlights opportunities to
contribute to the project itself
so you'll notice places where
contributions can be made
so you can see actually
or you know create an expectation that
doesn't exist yet
so you can see on the left side is going
to be is the list of all the
expectations show some attributes at a
high level um so you can see you know
what level of readiness is it in from
production beta before that experimental
before that uh what data sources uh
support the expectation
um and then on the right side your your
detailed view
description uh docstring
which is the next slide and then uh some
tests as well and example data so feel
free to check that out look for
opportunities to to contribute or
create your own
so
in the uh spirit of building this
gallery something new and exciting uh
that's happening is the introduction of
expectation packages so packages are a
group of expectations
made to be the standard of data quality
in its category
the purpose of these packages are to
enable data practitioners to surface
tests for their specific data quality
needs in bulk
so when an individual is working with
geo finance pharma
pii
dealing with semantic types
maybe they're creating something where
they want to ensure ethical ai and they
want tests for that
they can come to the expectation gallery
and grab the package that's relevant to
them and hopefully in the spirit of open
source they then can contribute back to
the package with some of the
expectations that they found that they
needed for those specific needs
so here you can actually see a mock-up
of
the first expectation package that we
have
made by the team at capital one
led by taylor turner as an expert of the
package so the role of the expert is to
help build a blueprint for the
expectation package and to help
establish it as that standard for the
category so it's also someone that can
monitor the progress of that package and
ensure that it's it's maintaining its
its uh
level of standard
so we're doing a hackathon right now to
accelerate the growth of these packages
um right now the packages that we're
working on are semantic types ethical ai
and geospatial packages uh we have
fifteen thousand dollars in prizes plus
some very unique swag for uh
for the people who participate
um and there's also some really easy
opportunities to participate at our
booth to help you get jump started for a
chance at those prizes so go check it
out uh the hackathon's running till
april 6th so plenty of opportu time or
actually it's not that much time to jump
in
and also i mean beyond just the cash
prizes you your name will be forever
attached to these expectations
and the packages that you contribute to
so there's more information at the booth
for the hackathon but my call to action
uh to use that we're seeking experts for
the packages uh to help us design the
blueprint create the standard for these
categories so if you're passionate about
ethical ai
geo semantic types or you know maybe one
of the categories i mentioned earlier or
category i haven't mentioned yet that
that you're passionate about and feel
you have an expertise
i would love to have you featured in the
gallery
and then also come to one of our
community events to talk about it
so again you know that you should know
the joe now say hello to me at the booth
email me or say hello and slack
so the last major step in supporting the
community is hands-on integrations with
ecosystem partners
so in order for us to consider great
expectations to be the open and shared
standard of data quality we need to work
with all the relevant tools that help
enable data practitioners
uh so that's why data ecosystem
partnerships have become a major focus
for us at superconductive and the
developer relations team
we've already had some success in
growing the ecosystem partners across
some key categories in the data stack
we've partnered with data orchestration
tools such as flight and dagster prefect
astronomer
data catalog such as atlan and datahub
synthetic data with y data interactive
notebooks with deep note data ops os
with multano and databricks and there's
some really cool stuff with databricks
coming soon
if you come to our monthly community
events you'll almost certainly see one
of these demos
and you can also catch them on youtube
if you haven't seen them yet
and we also maintained
we really want to maintain that pace
of having these integration ecosystem
partners coming in frequently
so to ensure that we do maintain that
pace
we've added an integration section to
help other tools integrate with great
expectations while documenting for
future users so you can check that out
in our documentation along with other of
the companies that have integrated with
us
so
if you're a tool in the data space that
would like to integrate with great
expectations again email me
booth slack
and uh
i hope all of you know this reference
of i've never seen this many power
rangers but i was very excited to use
this photo when i found it
cool thanks kyle
it's really fun just to see
i mean how far we've come as a community
and talk a little bit more about where
we're going next um i'm going to recap
briefly and then we'll save some time
for q a at the end
so first oh man the
slide is off
okay every organization is becoming a
data organization and every link in that
supply chain needs some concept of of
data quality when you think about really
what is data quality it's getting
those shared expectations creating
shared expectations about how that
nervous system works and when you think
about what it takes to get there
you need to share tools you need shared
language that's that's the job that we
are trying to fill in the ecosystem to
become a universal shared language or
should standard be like that better for
for data quality
it's going well so far
it's one of the fastest growing data
communities in the world and we're
excited to keep that going we have a lot
of specific ways that you can get
involved so if you have something cool
related to data quality related to great
expectations we would love to host you
at a community meetup uh and i say
related to great expectations definitely
emphasis on the related there like the
thing that has made a lot of the best
presentations in this forum has been
people who have like ingenuity and ideas
of their own that happen to tie into
what we're doing but that expand the
creative surface area of a lot
as a second thing
if you want to get more directly
involved in the creation of this library
we would love to get your help expanding
that vocabulary of expectations being
able to express more things and test
more things and turn them into
documentation there's a lot of work to
be done there
there's a lot of surface area so come
get involved whether that's the
hackathon or something else
and then finally since this uh this is
very much a conference of tool builders
if you are building one of those tools
and you want to integrate and you want
to help demonstrate how data quality can
be part of what you're doing please talk
to us because
we really do want to make it so that our
tools and the metadata and all that kind
of the useful workflows that come out of
that can be deeply integrated with every
other part of the data ecosystem
if you were here an hour ago there was a
great conversation about uh it should
like what should the one pane of glass
for data be um like what what's the one
metadata metadata system to rule them
all and i think the
consensus was there isn't one right
they're gonna be a lot of different
places where people have to work a lot
of different stakeholders who have to
work together in order to get their data
systems working and we want the
information about data quality that we
can encode and share to flow to all of
those other places
so
that's what we're working on that's kind
of our statement about what comes next
for great expectations as an open source
project
we are deeply deeply committed to open
source and community building and um
hope that comes through and hope that we
can find ways to work together thank you
thanks everyone